morning Millennials I'm so excited
because Ben is coaster yeah it's just
it's a staple now in homes across
America oh my god it just feels so good
like to be sitting here again you know
yeah it does mean Margo what we made the
journey from Philly last night at like
midnight
honestly Philly's so close it and like
we just happen to have like two slow
drivers but Ben is like an insane driver
and I think he could have made the drive
in an hour and a half
it really is close it's just so crazy
all these bustling metropolis is just
right in our backyard and it was like
very similar in New York vibes
it was so [ __ ] hot enjoy the city and
the streets smelled like hot garbage so
it really felt like I was home you know
it was great we did four shows and they
were all sold out
and they weren't lit as how honestly
like I never knew I had like you know
like I never if I do a show I really
never know if I do a good job and so
it's nice to have a marker there who's
like has no shaking the game and she can
just be honest with me and I felt like I
did a really good job like I really grew
as a comic this week which is you know
as comics you always want to grow
oh wait and the feedback was so positive
and like the the Philly people you know
I have like the joke that Philly people
are terrorists they were in their own
city when they won the Superbowl they
were very receptive and they were like
they knew that they were terrorists and
they like loved it do you know what I
mean yeah except for like one girl but
she was fine it was great like and I
just I love when people message me like
honest feedback like it was really hot
in the venue I'm like that's not my
fault and I couldn't have agreed more
you should have seen me after every show
they were hot imagine how you felt I
need two fans on stage I was enough
after each show I literally looks like I
ran the marathon like it was so crazy
Wow
and I had to like you have indigenous
hair and makeup or did you do it
yourself I did it myself and I got a
blowout before you Monday morning that
stood the test of time but like when I
woke up on Tuesday it was my hair was
just straws I could have like drank it
out of them and someone would yell to me
because it was plastic but it's not
plastic you guys we haven't talked about
the war on straws in a while but it is
taken on like a whole like it seems like
the moment we started talking about it
it really started to become a thing
right and it's as most things do don't
you polarizing subject as people some
people are like so gung-ho like don't
use a straw like you're killing the
turtles nose but then other people are
like straws make up for like point zero
three of the plastic in the ocean don't
quote me on that number but it's
something very small like that and us
straws like straws from United States
are even less than that number like why
are we starting with
adrian grenier um actually what I did
here was that America exports a trash
like to China to dispose so it's not
under our name but like it's from us
anyways we have a jam-packed show free
we J so we really can't dilly-dally
you know we're people and not that we
ever do not that we ever do sorry I and
I just was about to confuse Philly I was
gonna say were they saying dilly dilly
but that's like a New England thing Eric
Decker did you see that hot-ass picture
of him you also know that was an ad for
Gatorade in tune with what's necessary
crossover tune so in 2000 tune premium
content I have some premium content of
my own coming out later today I just
show you how I add it's really good it's
really oh so wait super quickly I wanted
to give an update because we did a dear
toasters on Monday and we got a message
from one the subject and it was the tier
toasters about the girl who was dating a
guy and she taking to his family and he
thought she thought that he was like
being shady like not wanting to tell
anyone because she was trans turns out
this was like this happened like a month
ago she was like literally the second
after I wrote in I never heard from him
again he completely goes to me right
dick so always trust your instincts is
the moral of the story there but like
that is so true you feel if you can feel
someone if you feel anymore something
like something's not right it's cuz it's
not right and even on the bachelor
finale like Blake was starting to get
like that feeling that sinking feeling
and it's cuz it wasn't right God gives
you a warning in your belly it's called
a fart and you can either listen to it
and be ahead of the curb or you can
ignore it and you can get downtown
national television it's up to you and
crying to a napkin
after you propose which is just like so
sad like they usually stop the person
right I was talking about this after the
show yesterday with Rachel cuz I we
talked about so much about The Bachelor
and I know not everyone watches so
honestly just for a chill and say she's
everything a pro I am absolutely in love
with her like there's nothing she could
do that would make me not respect the
[ __ ] out of her I respect the hell up
she's still loitered Rachel we need to
bring her on it for a retainer
she's a lawyer she's an ESPN
correspondent you know that host job is
never done another reason she's an
influencer she's a revolved girl she
said revolve Bermuda was amazing it was
even better than it looked that's
honestly that makes me feel better
because like I'm like they're not even
mean fun but they are they are let
come ah anyways what were we just
talking about so much to so much today I
got the toaster update oh the pit in
your stomach trust it Blake sorry
bachelor finale like was just shook the
world you didn't watch though
no I didn't hey intern Margo would you
pick up this phone call oh here oh thank
you thank you intern Margo Thank You
intermarry you're doing a fantastic do
that is gold neces publicist I'm sure
that they are lost because everyone gets
lost coming here but by the way Whedon
even nowadays such a special day leaves
me and Gigi but she's dropping the Gigi
just go Nessa from Shahs of Sunset
coming on in a little bit and I'm very
very excited I have a lot to talk to her
about I'm very very excited and that's
not even that's just the tip of the
iceberg because also today the day is
here
Campos tickets are going on sale yeah
for patreon members at 6 o'clock today
six o'clock tonight so if you're not a
peach remember honestly just do it for
this month because I have a feeling it's
gonna sell out I've been like telling
everything every vendors Nikon shake
well every vendors like how many people
are you expecting like we're expecting a
full sellout well you see you got it
you gotta talk the talk no it's really
exciting like we've worked super hard on
this and honestly I mean in our eyes and
meet across Turkey and I really just
want this to be a success because I
really want this to be a thing like
every year maybe like we get to a point
where it's like two months it's like the
whole camp I don't know like I just
can't be running our own camp right I
mean that's our dream we've always said
that's our dream a long time you dated a
guy whose parents own a camp the dream
the dream and now he is a camp director
oh my because I can't right now right
your lighting I just think like that
this whole concept has so much potential
so I'm really excited for this to happen
and like be a great success and then
next year we can like plant it a little
bit further out and just like maybe get
the cost down but like this is gonna be
so epic if you're not a peach round
member please become one tickets go on
sale tonight at 6 p.m. Eastern time for
patreon members and tomorrow and then
regular non patreon members will go on
sale tomorrow afternoon so whatever time
I know so like I'm so in like a private
Facebook group for all the toasty
campers like it's gonna be so epic I
need to get more Sophie shorts and like
some some workout clothes I'm so so so
excited and
I just want to say there's a lot of the
logistics will be available for you on
the event price ticket page but just
know once you get to kam toast you're
not spending a dollar you're not going
anywhere
everything is nicer for you drink fun
friends it's all you are you at camp
toast do know that you can arrive
anytime on Thursday after two o'clock
and that you must leave anytime on
Sunday before 10:00 I am yeah Sunday
that's a hard out we got to be out at
10:00 a.m. so if you're booking flights
just know that if you have to leave
Saturday night we understand Thursday
you can start arriving at 2 p.m. but
arrival whenever you want all this
information is on the event by page so
read it thoroughly well give you guys
like and if you're flying in these extra
thoroughly because there's a lot of
information Airport information if
you're coming from New York uh it'll be
easier for you yeah it's only like an
hour and a half drive and it's a
beautiful drive so with all that said
and without further ado here are the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast cool okay first up
breaking news this morning Carrie
Underwood is pregnant singer is
expecting her second child with Mike
Fisher and she posted a really strange
announcement on Instagram that someone
tagged me and saying she's pregnant and
I and I looked at it I said this doesn't
mean she's pregnant I mean she's going
on tour she announced a tour in a
pregnancy god I know so you're going on
tour while you're pregnant that seems
strenuous as hell I don't know for some
reason these days every story about
Carrie Underwood and her family gives me
like the biggest pet right because
there's there's so much unknown there
there's so many questionable ons and so
many unanswered questions no and it's
like I know she went from being
America's Sweetheart to being America's
pit I had cream like I used to just see
her and I'd be like she's the American
dream like she went on American Idol she
was so country so American so beautiful
like everyone really saw the talent in
American Idol right and then she like
had this career that was so astronomical
and she became really a full-time
America's Sweetheart and just like that
once you have down the stairs and it's
all over she was a beautiful wonderful
perfect all-american girl beautiful
wonderful perfect marriage
in girl also her song cried pretty like
just left us with even more questions
right the tyree the one army was all
about
have you heard hunter Hayes's new song
Margo and me listen to it in the car
it's so beautiful and it's like so sad
and like his songs were like always so
sad no it's like dear God are you sure
that you don't mess up like why does
like why don't I deserve even a piece of
love it was like heartbreaking and when
he came on the breath he was dating
Raylan's friend and she came to cuz she
was like a fan of yours Libby this makes
me feel like they broke up Oh unless
it's one of those songs he wrote a while
ago and is just releasing now but that
must be hard to sing like dear God do I
deserve a piece of love it just like
broke my heart it's not remember that
the song that made him famous was like
about how like people call him ugly like
it's like so sad yeah he looks so sad
behind as I know I know and I'm every
time I listen to the song I'm like I'm
enjoying this thoroughly but I just want
to text someone to make sure he's okay
right he's given who are you good
anyways wait also just talking about
like people who write songs that are sad
I made a Taylor Swift fan account did I
tell you this I said it on the show yet
I don't think I'm a yes on the show
swifty with no job and honestly like I'm
really excited about it speaking of the
new jobs Theo and I had such a day
yesterday your continent and sturm
stories was just premium as [ __ ] like he
just really brought out the best in me
is all I can say we watched the movie of
the months of the week together which
we'll talk about in a little bit because
there's um I was disappointed sister
okay I mean I have to explain myself
we'll get to it we'll get to it anyways
rest of the story you might be wondering
you're asking Carrie why is your tour
starting in May well yeah she said
revealing balloons spelling out baby
above her head Mike and Isaiah and I are
absolutely over the moon and excited to
be adding another little fish to our
pond okay so she's not going on tour
pregnant oh that's a cute um look little
fish our pond
Mike Fisher oh that's cute I didn't put
that together okay
takes away one visit one ounce of the
bin still here that she's also going on
tour with Maddie and Kay who I love me
too even though they kind of fell off
the face of the earth for a little well
maybe they just have any music coming
out and that's why they're going on
actually that's like a great pairing
there's also another artists run away
June but they put Luke Pell in their
music videos oh so where I can't take
them seriously I'm also speaking of
concerts we are going this week
and if any toasters are going Madison
Square Garden with Jason Aldean Lu combs
and Lauren Alaina which is so crazy that
like I'm literally gonna be the first
person they're come there from Lauren
Alaina and Lu combs and like I might not
stay for Jason me and Margo said the
same thing in the car last night like
I'm not really interested in Jason
Aldean ho people trying to guess what do
you think the lineup is you think it's
more in Luke I'm wearing Luke Jason I
think that's sober see just four worn
away and I feel like she's really having
her moment like she's playing a Madison
Square Garden that's a really big deal
and like I'm like kind of friends are we
like texts so I'm really excited
wait you have two techniques Luke Holmes
girlfriend I did already last night and
she's just her I don't know she's
toaster she's just like while they're
New York get Luke on the toast Luke on
the toast hey Luke on the toast
Luke um it's just you know tour life
like you're in one city and you're gone
the next day
I mean you know all about it oh my god
Margo the DJ t-totally we were in the
car last night listening to Lauren alena
album and you know the song about how
she's always on the road three six years
of missin home for three minutes on the
radio I was like Margo this song as me
my brother's son didn't see him turn one
six weeks of missing home for you know
totally but like I like have so much fun
well I'm like this song is about me yeah
I mean that's the beauty of her music it
just it it transcends I know and also
like I I was having you know a meeting
with my team like one person we were
discussing you know what's next cuz this
whole journey Jean store is really like
a test to see like if I can be comic and
it's like it's what the people want
right and if until parts what the people
want cuz like most of the shows are sold
out Palm Beach tomorrow a couple tickets
left to go snatch I'm girls my job calm
what's next 2019 like 52 weeks out of
the year I'm gone for like 30
oh I thought you were gonna say you're
gone for 52 weeks I don't know because I
have to give them dates I'm like Jack is
getting married and my birthday like I
can't be bothered
but like Ron for 30 me I know I'll have
to man up to take the test on the road
you know pack this up you know I'd be
happy to do I know like I think it might
involve a tour bus which I everyone I
would have to come Wow okay well we'll
describe us down so treacherous I'll
send you my rider anyways next story
what everyone's talking about Courtney
and Eunice have broken up oh yeah in a
very bizarre way yes so it's over for
Courtney and Eunice Benzema the Keeping
Up with the Kardashians star 39 has
reportedly split from the 25 year old
male model and he's already travelled to
Mexico and flaunted PDA with another
woman according to photos obtained by
TMZ then they're not together morning
Jose right the pair got together in 2016
I actually saw it on the morning toast
the breakup comes after their long
summer vacation in Italy as well as his
controversial comments on her social
media photos that's what you need to
show to get likes he rode in a since
deleted comment on a picture that showed
a bit of her but after Kardashian's fans
took to his Instagram to comment on all
of his shirtless posts then Jima seemed
to learn his lesson and commented on
another one of Courtney's post oh
they're just going back through the
Instagram drama basically he was spotted
like hoisting up another woman and then
he's like putting weird [ __ ] on his
Instagram stories about how we don't
know him and we're trying to bring him
down I don't know you from Adam man what
he said was he was in Mexico with 12
people and like TMZ just decided to
capture one moment where he was like
like fooling around with a girl like
they weren't even kissing they were just
like I don't even know like a
two-year-old like tumbling around on the
ground so those pictures like look like
something but he was like they're really
not and I kind of get him like being
annoyed about that but like sorry you
are Matt we're dating the Kris Jenner
Harvey Levin machine like why did you
think just a pawn and what's weird is
that they actually were broken up
because this seems like this the sort of
thing where it would be taken out of
context and it looks like he's cheating
on her but he's not I can agree that
he's just like being frisky with a
friend even though like I don't touch my
friends like that either um but you know
everyone's different but they actually
were broken up so I hadn't heard that
they were broken up until these photos
came out but then it could and so it was
a weird way of it it was like backwards
but it was just Kris Jenner being like
Christian unis you're in the doghouse I
you touched a girl you're done totally
and honestly that girl was really cute
they they look right together them too
like Courtney you're too old for this
like go back to Scott honestly and you
saw like Kim is being an amazing sister
like shading Eunice on Instagram and
then though Kourtney Kardashian is
ungrateful for all the fruits of Kim's
labor right she bought her [ __ ]
career and bio shoes I bought her a
[ __ ] career Kim likes enews his
Instagram posts like that were pictures
of Kourtney and Scott through the years
like saying maybe now they'll get back
together but not right for each other I
feel like
that's like kind of happy with Sophie I
feel like Scott is happy and honestly I
think Kourtney is just like an unhappy
person and I think that she is like
there no man will satisfy her because
she's like really just like not
emotional
she doesn't care I feel like she's fine
after her and unis broke up her life
hasn't been affected and it hasn't
changed at all right and that's why like
in some way actually thought Eunice was
perfect for because it was just like
companionship and like someone to go to
you're up with hmm but you know yeah
like I don't feel like Kourtney's face
by this at all I feel like her life will
go on and it is yeah hard with oh that
was beautiful thank you and wonder what
Eunice is gonna do next like is he gonna
stick it out in the thirst lane or is he
gonna just like go back to male modeling
right cuz I don't think he was a
relatively popular male model until the
core the Kardashian curse so hopefully
it'll the court the Kardashian cares
will run its course on Eunice and just
virtus career like it did everyone
else's totally okay this next story is
so crazy and just so relatable okay
Leo's chin gets edited out of once upon
a time in Hollywood promo pictures okay
so we have a photo we have a photo it'll
be after before and after and you know I
am a connoisseur of the double chin not
anymore
I'm sure can you give us your take I'm
sure can you do an analysis so you know
I don't think it's like Leo's in great
shape you know it's not a fad thing but
you know it's sometimes gravity takes
its course when you get to a certain age
in a turtleneck yard you know it's being
propped up so they're really like this
isn't anything like Leo could have done
necessarily and what I'd like is that in
an edited picture they still left a
little chin because you always have to
remain believable you know he's in the
tournament so they took out like 3/4 of
it and left just like a little quarter
which was very smart because for him to
not have one wouldn't really make sense
and honestly his character probably
requires one so I think this is a good
job on the behalf of Hollywood they
didn't you know curve any backgrounds or
anything but sometimes they do or remove
someone's arm legs he still looks hot
you know yeah but it's just sad that
they got caught you know and it's sad
for Leo except he's I'm sure I said it's
just incredibly awkward now and I'm like
we know you edit out your chin like
that's something I do we
gonna be editing our photos the same way
you know right like your Leonardo
DiCaprio are we gonna be once upon a
time in Hollywood now I think double
chins only only honestly I've been
getting so many questions about my chin
like and I keep saying what it is people
like you haven't told us I'm like I'm
not hiding it from you like I say Morgan
people in the back so I was like really
interested in getting kybella and when
Jackie and I went to dr. Kesey's office
who's Ramona's plastic surgeon great
plastic surgeon we highly recommend we
just went for like a consultation we
wanted to see what our options were and
I told her I'm like honestly I hate my
neck so much like and I don't really
know if kybella works like what do you
suggest and you couldn't take the pain I
couldn't take the pain she was like
she's like I have the perfect thing and
you know didn't know but Olivia told me
she invented this surgery and patented
it she's the only person who could do it
I think that's so crazy yeah it's called
the natural neck lift basically she took
a needle mad hard and sucked all the fat
out of my neck and my lower cheeks and
my jaw and I was swollen for a while and
then like two weeks later I had a
brand-new face I love when that happened
me too i I just I can't recommend it
enough honestly was so expensive and I'm
still like digging myself out of the
hole that it put me in but I would have
paid double Wow maybe triple honestly
I'm glowing review I'm so happy I'm so
happy for you I've been using a new
machine by heard this M scott machine
that gives you abs and the feeling is so
crazy like instantly Poe was I would
take a nap like it was so relaxing this
like it's just it's the act of like
doing sit-ups like thousands of setups
so your stomach is like contorting and I
actually feel like it's really working
out two more sessions
that's it interesting I'd like to see
results from that right and then like
I'm going on vacation so like you'll see
in my pictures whether or not it worked
okay I'll try not to edit two months
very exciting very exciting stuff
anyways Leo if you need dr. Chang
Jeezy's number DNA for you you can find
her an Instagram for more information
honestly
Leonardo peppers and surround is so
boring and I really do appreciate all
the positive things he's doing for our
environment and he's doing the Lordsburg
but like put a selfie up every now and
again like just give the people what
they want
I don't follow him and you know what
like he only he like follows three
accounts like UNICEF Animal Kingdom and
like two ASPCA that come on like I don't
know about how he feels but I'm really
ready for him to settle down like
running around with all these like
Instagram models is getting very sad and
like he really should have married Bar
Refaeli and called her today I couldn't
agree more or Blake Lively or Gisele or
Nina Agdal actually they were really
happy together we're really happy
together and she has fallen so far but
from from leo but like he's dating that
girl kami Moroni and they've been
together for a really long time she's
literally 98
surely yes sorry he dates these girls
for a long time like I know it's so
weird it's like a perpetual boyfriend
it's not like a revolving door but like
the door opens once a year but you know
who was a perpetual boyfriend George
Clooney but he had like the dignity to
like do it with appropriately aged women
like honestly justice will never be
served enough for Stacy Keibler for what
she went there and then how she ended up
like justice because she could never
compete with in a mall you know nobody
none of us I mean she's happy I guess
but like she's not married to George
Clooney she's not gonna be the first
lady in a couple years
no no she's not but George Clooney might
be the first man actually totally I'd
vote for a mile on the floor for George
Clooney I feel like George made a
mistake if they get divorced they should
run against each other I think George
made a big mistake and marrying a mile
because I think he thought he was like
marrying someone who would be like a
prestigious wife but like she's
completely overtaken like he's a nobody
to me Amal is everything in this world
and I don't even look at George like
he's the [ __ ] off my cheek oh I totally
agree like she is just a list in every
category of rebadged politics
lifestyle exile human rights travel trap
I don't know she's just everything I
know literally never forget that little
white dress she wore on the boat driving
up to like her engagement dinner and
like it was like Valentino and I have
like stitched flowers in it like he was
just so epic oh my god we haven't talked
about her in a while
no also let's just being private and
saving the world and that's what you do
do we think that she had a surrogate
yeah I don't think about it um I think I
think about circuits all the time
because the NT is a really eye opening
to the surrogate thing and how there's
like a couple surrogates in Hollywood
who like everyone uses there's a royal
surrogate yeah that's crazy
no actually they're not really related
to the surrogate it's just like uterus
but like they have to have something
action they've a connection give the
same road yeah no but like there's a
royal
sorry surrogate that they say Meghan's
because she's like super skinny and
she's pushing 40 so like she might not
be able to get pregnant most people use
the surrogate because they can't get
pregnant or they just don't want to
carry a chest so there's both like and
that's like the [ __ ] up part like if
you use a surrogate just because you
don't want to like get fat which like I
kind of understand like that's like the
less immoral way but like do whatever
you want and there's people who use a
surrogate because they can't get
pregnant that's what they say about
Megan Markel and that's what they said
about Kate Middleton for her third kid
got it like she was able for the first
two times and then for the third time
she just like took a back seat I feel
like that's there like an heir and a
spare and then like you know I'm sorry
one for fun right one for one you can
actually enjoy right what's crazy about
them all is like she literally whether
or not she had a surrogate like she got
pregnant with twins boy and a girl
farted them out and now she's done you
know breasts got pregnant again she got
married farted out to twins a boy and a
girl and like saved the world legit in
the same here what did she do before
2017 no but like she's she's done like
it's it's so creepy
it's like so much to do I know that
pregnancy is gonna take everything from
me you but I honestly look forward to it
see my my god you get excused for so
much right there was a girl at my show
who was like breastfeeding it was like
her first night out since giving birth
and I asked her if I could try her
breast milk and she said yes and I was
gonna do it on stage I completely forgot
oh and I really wanted to do it I just
didn't care so it tastes like I've heard
it's like not good yeah okay next up in
mine expansion Elon Musk wants to take
Tesla private at four hundred and twenty
dollars a share I mean can you take
something private oh I didn't even think
is it public already so Tesla CEO Elon
Musk said to say he was considering
taking the company private at a price of
420 dollars a share for 20 he ain't
[ __ ] around
posting his intentions on Twitter and
causing the stock price to jump seven
percent before trading was temporary
halted around 2:00 p.m. so it's public
now the Tesla closed up 11% at nearly
three hundred and eighty dollars after
trading resumed as a public company we
are subject to wild swings in our stock
price that can be a major distraction
for everyone working at Tesla musk said
Tuesday in an email to employees he also
said the quarterly financial
requirements of being a public company
quote puts enormous pressure on Tesla to
make decisions that may be right for a
given quarter but not necessarily right
for the long term he's such a genius
it's like no wait that makes a lot of
sense I don't want to go public at a
societal pressure of just like
in public and like watching your stock
rise and fall not interested and then
like everyone doesn't mean to say about
it but you know you're doing good work
and like you make a decision because so
that our stock will go up but in the
long term it's the wrong decision right
and then like the stock plummets just
like one day because like that's how the
stock market works and like some
engineers like worried about his family
you know right when like everything's
really fine oh my god I didn't even
realize being public it's like I pay a
pit know private all the way I didn't
know you could take it back I don't know
you could undo ctrl Z your private
public company apparently if anyone can
it's on and I respect his decision I
wonder if anyone's ever done that before
I feel like we'd be the first we should
invest in Tesla like we need to put our
money where our mouth is no i-i've been
thinking recently that I really do want
to invest but I think we're always
reporting on like big losses like you
know anything like we're never like oh
everyone made a lot of money this week
it so it's like shareholders are out you
know like I don't feel like there's any
company super stable and I used to say
like I would 100% invest in Facebook no
and now I'd be like okay well you know
what I'd invest in Apple it's super
stable but like they're at their peak
trillion like it's a trillion but I
would invest we'll remember when Kanye
bought Kim stocks for Herbert
yes about her Amazon Apple I think
adidas because yeah works with them and
I forget what else I didn't go back to
that getting that screenshot and buy all
those one no definitely invest in Amazon
I would definitely what's like a young
company that has like a lot of pause you
know but you know I would have missed in
more of the necessities tech is - it's
too wobbly I would invest in like steel
you know things we need water can you
invest in water that's what I would have
messed it
hydrogen peroxide oxygen I would invest
in the things we need I wouldn't invest
in straws
hell no I would not invest in Starbucks
no [ __ ] that cuz we're taking them down
no definitely Amazon no it's Amazon's
gonna take over the sound of the only
tech company that I see a bright future
for yeah but then I would invest in like
I mean I don't wear glasses so I
wouldn't mess in this specific company
but companies like Warby Parker did it's
so weird that you said that because I
was like scouring for my followers the
other day like I got a brand new fellow
as a CEO of Warby Parker I'm like why
are you following me
hilarious verified so I mean who is this
a chopped at CEO at Warby Parker very
cool I would invest in you guys at my
work glasses but I just I don't think
that they're public though Oh Mike
speak to what they do Camargo become
glasses do you wear like oh my god Margo
wears over sashay and before that she
was wearing Tiffany like we're safe
oh sorry we were safe before the choose
wearing dolce gabbana we got to get
Michael Mike kind of help me a Theo cam
we need to stitch can turn that one
right there
got it okay but another is at the left
story no fifth and final story is my
favorite story of the day go grab and
it's just my favorite NFL's first male
dancers will hit the sidelines this
season equality for all finally NFL fans
will see history made the season and has
nothing to do with what goes on between
the goalposts the LA Rams in the New
Orleans Saints will have male
cheerleaders dancing on their squads for
the first time
dancers Quintin Peron and Napoleon
ginnis have been preparing for the NFL
season since they made the Rams cheer
squad in March quote still can't believe
I'm one of the first males in history to
be a pro NFL cheerleader Jenny's tweeted
after being selected other teams like
the Colts and the Baltimore Ravens have
stuntman USA Today reported but / owning
ginnis will be dancing alongside their
female teammates and doing the same
moves oh my god I'm so here for this I'm
so here for this I feel like no chillin
squad it's complete without gender
neutrality right like we also bring it
on right the best teams how can you go
back to all-female teams after that and
honestly in bring it on when they were
like at the qualifiers and like there
was just some only girl
um squad so I was like they're not even
close to being as elevated as like the
East Compton clovers or the Rancho carne
Toros no and on the ranch and when a
tourist starts like sounds like a taco
I'll have the rental-car de Toro and
iconic tacos
yeah yeah and when we went we went to
Palos Verdes weekend for a conference a
couple years ago and we just like the
whole time like scores I mean they were
always so much yeah yeah
and you don't realize that as a kid but
like then now you're grown up and like
we're like how do they have such big
houses no totally it's like enough space
in their house for like the whole squad
to practice right and like do I have a
TM tattooed on my forehead and I was
thinking more da d y no wait this is so
great because like I think a boys are
great in a cheerleading squad for sons
but the obvious but like it's 2018
honestly anything boys can do girls can
do better and anything girls can do boys
can do better like I just think it's so
hello
so like there's so many male-dominated
fields where like the woman is better
and there are so many male-dominated
fields where the woman is I mean and
there are so many female dominated
fields where the males that are like I
think it's funny how like the number one
food network star whereas like cooking
is a woman's job like its Emeril Lagasse
you know Mario Batali and not that
they're like the picture of masculinity
but still Mario Batali and then they're
like they're just like male-dominated
fields like computer science where
people like Carly cross or at the front
okay I was a hundred percent you know I
just think it's funny how like there are
these stereotypes for like jobs that men
should have and jobs that women should
have and like in the man jobs the woman
is the best and in the woman jobs the
man services they just goes to show that
those stereotypes mean [ __ ] so
traditional so and also like there are
so many fabulous like fantastic male
dancers like when I watch videos of
dancing on YouTube and like just let's
get it all in there we doesn't have to
be like rah-rah-sis-boom-bah
jacket and so many dancers like their
dream is like to grow up and be like a
DCC right I don't know so when your
attention and boys should have that same
dream too when you're a dancer they're
like a few jobs that are you see just
it's like it's like a pro athlete
cheerleader it's the Rockettes there's
like a couple jobs that are so a bit
good it should be open to everyone I
totally agree um I can't leave I forgot
to say this do you remember this I just
wouldn't you don't you remember
something from your like growing up and
I remember it when I was in Bogota
Berlin again and I love to try
everybody's : but only the best one
survived my fav you're kind of alter my
favorite vine of all time by chrish
short for christian um I recently
started following him on Instagram and
then I was like being him in that video
of you and Abe I mean he's so funny
and we like diem now and I went on his
Instagram live and also please do the
corn thing please do the corn thing and
he did it oh my god it's the best and
honestly the vine out of context makes
no sense but his caption was the girl
who takes judging the corn competition
too seriously
I mean I love to try everybody's corn
but only the best ones survive like
genius comic genius comic genius
oh my god and also it's not even if I'm
going up that's just from like the vine
days but it's everything like there are
these iconic vines and that is one of
them for us I don't even know if like
for the world the world is an iconic
Viner and I think he had more popular
ones but for some reason that corn one
spoke to us spoke yeah just like corn
and a deep deep level okay we need to
talk about the toast movie of the week
now because we're we hit you at the Fast
Five you are so important so was Lenny
doodle okay so little children no
children Kate Winslet haha Chuck Wilson
um Jennifer Connelly so I understood
what you mean started studded cast not
that many people ever heard of it I saw
in the description was based off of a
book oh so I was actually very hopeful
um but it was beyond strange and at
first they lost me when they kiss in the
flick the hug was kind of funny and then
they kissed in the park and I was like
okay this is insane too public
it was like okay you know what I'm gonna
just like this isn't my type of movie
but I'm gonna enjoy it and like just see
like what the people are watching and it
was terrible and nothing happened
nothing happened and my favorite part of
it honestly was the fact that the guy
who plays the pedophile is also in
chowder island George Noyce and he
castrated himself right and all I could
think about was George Noyce and it
brought me back to shutter island which
was a high point of 20 of the week and
this was a low point okay so I just feel
like I need to explain myself because at
no point did I say it wasn't amazing no
but the toast movie of the week is for
amazing you know also just be for
interesting movies like I find it
interesting that there is a Kate Winslet
Patrick Wilson Jennifer Connelly Mosiah
Mensing George George George Noyce
movie that like nobody's ever heard of
and it was like such an odd movie and it
was like an art film but then there was
like weird sex scenes and then it was
like a pedophile element to it and that
she's never cared about her kid likes a
big nipple - okay
like I'm just saying like there was so
many like I just think it was like I
it's like a novel idea like I just think
it was a funny movie for us to talk
about like well I never said it was good
most of us paid 399 to rent it on Amazon
valid you feel bad and we just all
contributed funds
something that was not premium and I
think it was going forward the toast
movie of the week should be premium
informative spark interesting dialogue
and above all interesting but I do think
that that movie sparks interesting
dialogue no like I'm only talking about
it because the kettle bells mom was like
so sad she was she was really sad and
then like but they're trying to make us
be like sympathetic for the pedophile
but then he really is discussing jerking
off in front of that like poor oh my god
that was terrible like I just I can't I
can't in a Shan and there's a reason why
no one ever heard of it it was because
it was terrible and Kate Winslet was
hoping no one would see it like sorry
Kate wait let me call you out I'll be
fine and why would the [ __ ] was it
called little children it wasn't about
the children the whole time you were
thinking like stop having an affair your
kid is living next to a pedophile but
she didn't know where no I wasn't the
whole time I the pedophile like wasn't
gonna harm anyone except for that girl
because he I don't know something set
him off on the date that date at first
before he got in the car was
masturbating it was a perfect date it
was a great first waiting on to the pool
the community pool it was like she was a
character in myself snorkeling he was a
heat wave but why are you smirking in a
pool like a community Playhouse pervert
yeah it was doubly weird that was
definitely weird and it was just it was
non-premium and it was very very long
and I think you owe me an apology
absolutely not and I think we sparked an
interesting conversation I think that
this was a wholly nothing like shutter
shutter island' Martin Scorsese like
genius okay but I just wanted a narrator
I took the idea of movie of the week as
like yes it needs to be like interesting
disparaging but I just think it's like
there's a classic movies that are like
[ __ ] hysterical and like I just think
this was like a funny movie I do I think
it's a good man I want to use suppose
movie of the week to learn more about
the world around us cuz I'm and because
that's how it's started me were saying
like we need to watch more like history
feel educational because that's the
easiest way for us to learn about
history without national treasure
without having to read a book right
that's how it started so next week's
movie of the week is the founder
risottos room that's the weekend of it
the founders that the most incredible
moment the founder is big it's a maze
it's a true story it's while it's on
Netflix I believe it's about one of the
most important institutions in this
country McDonald's how about got their
start and then became like the number
one the billion dollar company in the
world and so we will be discussing the
founder I I think we should talk about
it on Monday okay I know it's a short
but it's a short film and I've seen it
twice now and I've loved it both time
and I'm gonna watch it again for the
toast movie of the week so that we can
really get into it and it's like it's
not what you think
do you know what I mean no it's wild
just enjoy yeah anyways the only last
thing I want to talk about before we
bring alcohol Nessa is bachelor in
paradise premiered last night and her
usual like it was parody seal it was a
little slow considering I heard Rachel
Lindsay told us they had so much footage
that they actually stopped filming early
cuz like they didn't need anything right
so for them to like really drag out the
first day this teen Colton business here
are my thoughts well first of all my
first thought is that Bibiana is the MVP
of paradise already her
she goes she's talking about all the
guys here she's like I'm just gonna kill
him with booty I think that she is with
that guy in real life which guy David
she's standing next to him David rabbits
yeah she's standing next to him about
tremendous photo and they've been like
together because he lives in Florida and
so does she I think they're just like
paradise friends there were that many
bachelor people live in Florida and I
think if they were together she wouldn't
be so open about so I haven't seen that
sewed yet but I watched the theme song
because they put it on their Instagram
and I just have to say I missed like one
season like and I don't know what anyone
I don't know anyone yeah except that
girl Chelsea she was annoying as [ __ ]
right but she's really pretty and there
was like sure they kind of villainized
her but she seems to be like so nice
right and also they villainize crystal
true but like if I've learned anything
it's like The Bachelor is one big fat
lie and I'm sure Crystal's a really nice
girl and cheap but we're like she looks
so good she looks so good and like the
guy she deserves justice I feel like she
really didn't even do anything no I
agree nobody does anything I mean like
we learned that with Olivia Creed a yeah
like she was super nice and they made
her look like a psycho and like you
can't be that different Corinne like I
don't believe anything that The Bachelor
tells me to be that's why I absolutely
love REM Lauren and I'm so not here for
that that like universal hatred of them
I agree and I can't believe they went to
the Maldives and they didn't air it
hey why that's such a good TV like
that's like when Andy door friend met to
talk to Nick like that's epic they would
ever cut that out I mean I can
I feel like like bachelor nation heat
sorry Lauren and like so disliked the
producers but I love them they're the
only real couple they have not the only
real couple no they have a wedding date
set like right but like Jourdan and Jojo
don't yeah I like I love are you
mourning I feel like why does everyone
eat them I don't get it and he did the
right thing like he did he's allowed to
change his mind and he did it
respectfully and he gave back away like
yes uh he did it on camera so that
people who feel bad for and she was
about Trent and I'm he didn't wait too
long that they announced another
Bachelor and then she like she was gone
he did it perfect timing he did when he
was supposed to like seriously stop I'm
really not here for it I agree and she's
literally was so happy and after the
final rose she like had her back to
Chris Harrison cuz like she couldn't
stop looking again I'm like she got the
bachelor makeover they gave her but
we've they gave her Botox like she got
what she wanted stop or he could have
done it so much worse and he could have
done it off-screen and nobody knew what
happened and I feel bad for her B he
could have done it like two months later
when they had already announced TN t as
a Bachelorette no he gave her a life get
over it let him live his I'm so not and
Lauren is so cute and so pretty and I
love them together and they're so real
and if they break up they moved to
Phoenix and they have a house like stop
that's it
stop I concur sir the only other thing
that happened last night was Tia and
Colton and here's the thing there's
something like so weird because like
Colton was like ignoring to you but then
like immediately asked her out on the
date which was just like I feel like
Colton is definitely like teenager
middle school vibes yeah definitely and
he's like kind of being a fuck-boy and
people are saying that he's there for
fame but like people the batch I'm hard
ice contestants can't say that about him
because like you're all on TV right pot
kettle I don't know
hey pot this is the kettle you're black
so I just wish like it seems as though
they're kind of stepping around because
they don't want people to think that
they orchestrated this whole thing to
end up in Paradise together but even if
they did that romantic you got what you
wanted
sail off into the sunset like I can't
deal with the back-and-forth and like
Colton like being a fuck-boy when like I
don't I haven't gotten there treating
him like a fog way they're talking about
him like he's a [ __ ] away but he hasn't
done anything [ __ ] boy yet aside from
talking other girls before he picked Tia
but I think he just did that so it
didn't seem like he came to paradise
Brody yeah an actor he was being an
actor oh and the biggest actress usually
Kendall taxidermy
guys I don't know why I have it in my
head that she is like a paid actress I
don't know why look at it through that
lens everything she does she's an
actress to the hug she gives acting hugs
that she's literally made it so far and
like she was like what top three now
she's done Paradis she was on every
episode of Beca season where they had
friends like I don't even know her she's
the taxidermy girl if she were suppose
to be a joke this joke is going on way
to like joke is going on way too long
and it's like they're treating like
because she's such a great actress she's
able to be taxidermy weirdness like
having picnics in cemetery and she said
last night but then also like I don't
know how I could be so in love with
someone my heart feels like it's
breaking this one first episode that's
like what she says coming up like
everything she says is just soaked and
and it's like a written script just
think but like no one wrote it for her
like she is taking on the role of
actress like she got cast on bachelor in
paradise and it's like the role of a
lifetime she's just so excited to be
working you know and I feel like [ __ ]
those sad benefits she's such an actress
I can't take seriously a word she says I
feel like she's so fake and she keeps
like honestly I'm like super grateful
though because the season could be so
much worse and they could have had
backup Martinez on right but you know
she's a boyfriend it's not what I heard
now what I heard and she's not pregnant
either yeah anyway so that's something I
do only tell you what I heard though
because it's really mean but I know I
know you know and I was have been
wanting to say it but like it's so mean
and like IFIF I don't get to bed Carmen
I've had people say mean things about me
even if they're true and like I just
don't want like I'm not gonna say it but
do your own research don't be that
person without further ado it is time to
bring out the gold myself though I
didn't go and I said please pop up on
our insert I'm in our facebook feed and
our YouTube feed with any questions
about shots of sunset about the cast
about Lilly ghalichi
for Gigi we will do our best to get them
to her we're gonna take a quick break
and we will be back with the one the
only call Nessa
you
okay toasters welcome back we are very
very very excited for our guests today
we have Golnesa from Shahs of Sunset and
I'm purposely not saying GG because I
heard a rumor that you're talking to
Gigi Gigi is at bay for now she's
resting
okay she's resting Golnesa is back okay
but what about Loch NESA always living
with him good good yeah guys wouldn't be
what it is without LOC that's not
honestly that's right that's right I
just feel like I know everything about
you because I watched you for so long
now I just I love Shahs of Sunset I'm
such a big fan of the show I think it's
like one of the best shows on Bravo and
it is it is and you guys are so
consistent you've never had like a down
season because you guys just have these
robust lives and you have real
friendship yeah you've known MJ Reza for
how long 12 woah 13 year they've known
each other really a long time I know
Mike since I was 13 so I mean that's a
really long long way as we go back but
yeah we've all collectively known each
other somehow for a very long period of
time yeah and I always feel like I don't
know if I'm the only one I just there's
like a special place in my heart for you
and Mike you know and I just figured I
don't think one of these days but am I
wrong like you're very wrong that's a
typesetting know if Mike's changed so
much you guys he's I think that a whole
divorce and then having to watch at your
life on TV with everyone it's kind of
like a therapeutic process that happened
to him he's just become really sweet and
charming him just honest he's like you
know what I'm not ready to settle down I
just want to you know that's a bad thing
but just don't lie about it
exactly it's not go on yeah and you are
recently divorced I'm almost home oh
yeah girl that's not jinxing like a
knock on every kind of everything are
you sure are you on good terms of Shalom
do you guys talk we talk to you lawyers
it means basically do not ever
communicate with me that is so great you
still have your beautiful ring I still
have are you gonna sell it absolutely
not no we're gonna wear clothes make
some calls find a way to wear it I
listen at the end of the day it's a
piece of jewelry he gave us two cardio
bracelets and you silver guys necklaces
and all that stuff what's the difference
just take it off the finger and put it
on a different thing cocktail rings here
do that all the time you can actually
take the diamonds and make something
else yes a necklace here yes do it yeah
I mean you know figure I can't chop the
dime right that's okay and do we get to
see more this season of how that unfolds
you going through the divorce yes you
get to see sort of because we started
filming around the time where the
divorce really started getting really
and he decided to come for me
financially you know yeah so it became a
little messy oh so right now
everything's settled and he has agreed
to just stop everything sign and let me
be so good riddance month ago do you do
you feel like it's going to be painful
to relive it like I feel like it's hard
enough to go through something like that
then being on a reality show and then
watching it with millions of people
again and again is that painful it is
it's it's uncomfortable but it's also
it's a lesson like I'm literally
watching it and you know last season I
get his name tattooed on my body in
Israel this is and I'm getting these or
removal so you don't have it anymore
no no I do I do you guys will see you
know it was it was very difficult for me
because you're so angry with someone for
hurting you so many way it's not heart
like I'm not heartbroken I'm angry that
like you lied about so much wasted my
time much so you know it's it's hard to
watch but you know I'm happy he's out of
my life where was it at - it's right
here
oh wow it's actually pretty but it also
bans piece
it also means pin hello and that's why I
said the Israel being in Israel was a
big deal it was very amazing for all of
us to be in Israel together and it means
peace and you know it's just whatever or
whatever whatever there are actually
their worst tattoos cuz his name could
have been like Aaron and then there's no
other meaning for that you know how is
your family going reacting to this
because I know when you guys got married
it was a little tense between both the
families now that you're getting
divorced is your family what's the
what's the vibe like it's interesting I
was never connected to his family his
sister and I kind of got close but his
mom never approved to me because I'm not
Jewish so I guess you know they have
their racial issues to deal with in
their demons they'll meet there on their
day none of my business
but my family was fine with it what my
parents were pissed about was the
harassment that came from him afterwards
they were constantly being called
mourning tonight they were being texts
from him emailed what you would call
them from block members fake numbers
just any way to you know contact any one
of my friends my family it got messy it
got really messy so you know you'll see
this season how hurt I am I what you
guys are gonna see what MJ does right
because you know I'm going through hell
right now that was the lowest blow that
someone could have gone with you know
you could have called me a [ __ ] c-word
and anything hmm but that was low yeah
and what about your relationship with
your sister there is no relationship
with mine no I see my niece and nephew
through her ex-husband cuz he feels
about her just the same way I do so you
know are you is she on the season at all
not at all no they really are have no
interest in writing on Shahs of Sunset
that is so crazy it's a messy person so
they have no interest dead wow I want to
talk more about like the cast because
you guys have been doing a really
interesting arc in terms of the people
like I just can't believe that one point
in time Lilly ghalichi was on the show
like it is so hysterical like I just
think it's already
it was such a great season because Reza
was so ready to jump ship until ILI's
train until he was it and I was just
living for it and I just think the arc
of where we were and where we are now so
we're anywhere Lilly was and where Lilly
is now it's so bizarre I'm the only one
friends with Lilly I love her she
messages me all the time you know she's
been so helpful with my company Musa
right now and obviously who to take
pointers from other than Lilly like she
knows this so she's just being so
amazing and so helpful she's so pregnant
right now so she's like cool you know I
love cannabis but right now I'm pregnant
and I can't really promote this for you
right now I said don't worry pop it out
then do it right in the back right she
doesn't even she must have gained five
pounds like she looks a mission she just
gained the baby but little belly
letterings change the jus really
anything but so we are no longer with us
uh is that what I'm what I'm
understanding we are and when we spoke
with MJ she has not seen us as baby they
do not communicate what is your
relationship like with alsa um truth yes
well this is a little interesting um cuz
it has invited me numerous times to come
over meet the baby whatnot I just felt
like you know really didn't make sense
to me because aza
tended to be my friend more when cameras
were up oh and so now that you don't
have cameras anymore in your life and
all of a sudden you're you know reaching
out to really establish a strong
friendship which I really didn't feel
was present before that I kind of took a
step back so we communicate through
Instagram posts like oh good job for you
gratulations there you know but that's
as far as I go with awesome yeah
honestly I was really on your side until
she lied about the IVF thing the embryos
that was so busy ah if you if you go
back through this seasons what everyone
is finally seeing now were things that
maybe I was calling out yeah season two
and I was just like you're fake you're
yeah but not all this fake [ __ ] because
she was always saying I'm not like these
other Beverly Hills girls to worry about
what I'm wearing in this but now all she
posts is Gucci this person have ten have
exactly so it's like a walking
contradiction maternity well she made it
easy do you feel justified now
even though you got like so much [ __ ]
like seasons ago for like being hard on
her but like because she was playing
this role of like this a nice car but
like she really was kind of two-faced do
you feel justified now no I don't feel
any justification for that because it's
my it was my treason and it doesn't
matter what I think now it's like what I
told you so what I've been taught to old
for that that's very mature will get
burned on their own I'm fine I don't
need so give anyone a heads up anymore
we have a new cast mate but she's not
really new because she was like a part
time destiny yeah how do you know her I
don't I met destiny through Reza so they
go way back and then I find out she was
on the people's couch wave couch on
Braavos I thought that was the coolest
thing someone that used to critique us
is now on our show good for her good for
her girl she's great on the show I mean
it's only been one episode so far but
like she really like is a straight
talker
yeah I'm really like looking forward and
she has a great friendship with you yes
like this yeah and like she's an a good
friend like an honest but loyal friend
she and I are like two peas in a pod
like we are so similar we're very alpha
you know we have a lot of similarities
as far as loyalty loyalty everything to
us and not backstabbing your friends and
whatnot so she's [ __ ] awesome she's
yeah awesome which really is a great
addition and then you also have two more
new cast members brother and sister well
are they is just she's not a cast member
but friend is yeah shot a sister oh my
god they came on together she's acting
out to form on deal yeah okay cool
so far so good yeah get one free so this
season it seems as though you and Nima
like have a fun relationship going on or
the beginning of something mm-hmm where
do you guys stand right now hmm
you want to know are you guys cool right
now define cool oh that's where you big
fat no no no you guys really do have to
watch because um I'll just say he's I'm
a maneater
yeah I'm a maneater so anything if
anything or has had anything happened
you guys will see and
you'll see how I devour my meat good
good
you guys I think out of all the Bravo
trips take some of the most interesting
trips like you've been really all around
the world and they're both educational
but also you know turn up would you love
where do you guys go this season I'm not
good not good well this season is all
about MJ oh right so we didn't have time
to do a trip because you know we had a
lot of other stuff going on for her so
we go to Vegas still fun well you guys
live in LA so what do babies just like
deal for you guys so for us were like
yeah you went skiing in Big Bear we go
skiing a big bare no stain skier I love
skiing I'm an aggressive skier but it
was like off dirt think what about
staying on you guys guys wait I'm like
sweating for um like it looks like
spring it was hot but like we're also
like well what are we supposed to do
skiing team this is just awkward so I
mean no but you guys really have taken
some of the best trips and I just I just
find it what season is a seven mm-hm so
crazy like from where we started with
Sammi where's Sammy Sam he's still
friends with all of us yeah but you know
he's still just Sammy yeah I just think
where we started and where we are like
I'm just I've loved being a fan of the
show I just think and I and I've been on
different sides of history both types
I'm like sometimes I'm like oh my god
Reza how could units and I'm like yes
Reza's
like I just I'm really invested in your
friendship is it weird for you to have
people who know a lot about like you and
your family your sister with your
relationship and like your husband and
like tweet you things about it may be
negatively like how do you deal with
with morons
yeah I got over it it took me a long
time I think to get over that though um
maybe it's like two years now that I
just don't care anymore when it's really
bad disrespecting type of trolling that
is offending other people I will do a
clock back it will come in and I will
with an educated response serve them
their own ass sometimes it's necessary
sometimes it is necessary just to also
let your other loyal fans know that you
don't allow this and this is not what
you're about so it kind of I love
because I immediately see a hundred of
my fans coming
and shoo that person up for me good yeah
so I'm kind of those one or two trolls
they can keep drawing me yeah they can
grass but they like the attention who
you're us we have some viewer questions
for you first is a game of merry [ __ ]
kill sherv and nima and mike oh no we're
not gonna let you off scot-free like
that umm I would marry Reza because I
see how he is as a husband he cooks he
cleans he makes sure like the house is
taken care of he's he's really like a
good husband
I definitely Refik Mike I mean Turkey
sorry baby oh my god that was so epic
and I guess that leaves me damn you know
Mary I mean so spill sure bin
okay only cuz you know you save your
worst for the people you love the mouse
yeah he would understand accepted yeah
sure
um someone wants to notice Mike still
have his shoe company true gold sure
that's what it's called yeah I think he
does still have the shoe company I know
he's still making stuff okay he's a
little all over the place when it comes
to you know businesses it's not a
question who can't keep the fit you
can't believe the fit but it wasn't a
question so what will let you all right
do you think Reza and Adam will have
babies yes 100%
I don't think Adam would let Reza live
much longer without them having babies
Oh ed a question for you are you still
friendly with Bobbie Elsa who yeah okay
they were right I see it's not Indian
food what um
someone want to know how is your RA my
RA is doing really really really well
right now so I'm almost in a full
remission so takes like almost a year
from you know the time they say it's out
of your body so they kind of come off
the medication and you're completely in
remission so I'm almost there that's
great yeah it's amazing Wow um someone
wants to know would you want your own
spin on show about starting your medical
marijuana business that would be so
interesting oh my god over the live I
love to I think it's really tricky you
know I think a lot of people are still
looking
cannabis as a drug but it's still a
taboo so I think little by little the
media is catching on because so many of
us are talking about it on TV and write
this whole season you guys are gonna see
the whole birth of whoosah and all my
cannabis stuff so I hope one day we'll
but I mean yeah you know I have a lot of
other stuff cooking right now cuz I'm
about to you know get pregnant Wow oh
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna find you know
some sperm it's one more summer do it
what is like what okay so you're
building a profile for a sperm donor
what does he look like what are his
qualities that's what you know I need to
figure out obviously healthy and multi
is my main concern healthy and wealthy
so but yeah I would prefer strong dark
features so I want those dark eyes at
the dark hair full eyebrows you know I'm
looking for that give great eyebrows
yeah you really go but nice arc yeah
okay final question for you is we always
say like if we were ever we're you know
pushy just enough to get a show on Bravo
our favorite part would be going our
watch happens live because it just seems
like the best time yeah and you go on
what like once a season the way will you
go how many times do you go on like once
every season - um sometimes twice right
you know just depends on what's going on
is it the best time ever it's so much
fun and honestly it literally feels like
it's lasts only 20 seconds because I'm
having so much fun doing it and Andi
silly you know so it's just so fun but
it goes like this and I think it's
already do you do you drink for real
when they drink yeah yeah yeah come back
they're like doing this before I get out
there doing man yeah you know yes that
sounds so fun oh my god the dream just
keep working fine yeah look up there one
day thank you so much for coming I mean
so going right we love Shahs Chasseur on
Thursdays right yes there's on Bravo and
where can people keep up with you and
the new businesses and all your life
updates um bacon
on my Instagram its GG underscore
Golnesa or you know Musa calm with all
the cannabis related stuff that I'm
gonna be doing so I'm gonna change your
Instagram now that you're no longer GG
just to go mess up like Madonna I mean
like the artist or just a symbol
something that dumb well thank you bonus
I thank you guys we will see you
tomorrow tomorrow we have been
co-hosting us I will be in Palm Beach
make sure about tickets before it sells
out that's all we got cam shows tickets
go on sale for PGI members at six
o'clock page on back home special
morning toast if you're interested in
early access piece pillow
you